so yesterday - I found half a joint in
the parking lot which is unfortunate
because as it turns out Dwight finding
drugs is more dangerous than most people
using drugs let's go over some of these
symptoms of marijuana use shall we
you tell me who this sounds like
slow-moving inattentive dull constantly
snacking shows a lack of motivation I
like the people I work with generally
with four exceptions but someone
committed a crime and I did not become a
Lackawanna County volunteer sheriff's
deputy to make friends and by the way I
haven't looked to the left all right
whatever
are you the kind of doctor who gets
hooked on his own drugs I bet you are so
Andy tell me what happened I was reading
an encyclopedia and I tripped or fell
over and hit my head or brain helmet you
call it yeah he sneezed and smacked his
head against the wall that sounds about
right well if it's a concussion it's
extremely mild so I wouldn't worry about
it anything else bothering you
nope okay well I mean yeah I've got a
weird rash in my knee pit area and my
tongue on this side doesn't taste
anything anymore sometimes when I walk
my ankles make like a weird rattlesnake
sound what else things that are far away
from my eyes are fuzzy I once ate a Twix
with the wrapper on it and I've never
seen the wrapper come out also I've
swallowed every piece of gum that I've
treated for the past 25 years
I don't know broke my thumb when the way
over here just fix me well I can help
you with the thumb I don't have to give
you referrals for specialists for the
other thousand things Wow
thanks for nothing dr. Harris you're
welcome
Cumberland Mills and how did you get my
resume
oh no I'm very flattered don't get me
wrong I'm just not sure that it's my
official resume or if it's something
that maybe a satisfied customer posted
online what does it say under martial
arts training oh okay I'm gonna have to
supplement that could I have your fax
number would I ever leave this company
look I'm all about loyalty in fact I
feel like part of what I'm gonna be paid
for here is my loyalty but if there were
somewhere else that valued that loyalty
more highly I'm going wherever they
value loyalty the most Pawnee high prom
king and queen are Lucy Taylor and ND
Dwyer what I broke the box and I threw
away all the votes and I voted for you a
thousand times I should get on up there
King Dwyer not without my coin hi Pawnee
high as your prom king I am your ruler
salads my first decree of power is to
declare that the prom queen shall be my
wife April Ludgate who is the best thing
that's ever happened who came to prom
even though she hates it give me this
always next year no there isn't
I'm a senior this is your wife how old
are you he's 33 and I'm 47 slash
immortal get out high school okay I will
only need two things a roll of duct tape
and a knife I'm on it okay 30 minutes
relax please come back save the receipts
hey what hey wait wait I keep various
weaponry strategically placed around the
office I saved Jim's life with a can of
pepper spray
I had velcroed under my desk people say
oh it's dangerous to keep weapons in the
home or the workplace well I say it's
better to be hurt by someone you know
accidentally than by a stranger on
purpose
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster
I had to also I had a banana on the way
over here sorry I get why you don't want
anyone to know about Duke silver and you
don't have to worry your secret is safe
with me to even it out I'm gonna tell
you all of my secrets oh no that's not
necessary
I once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks I didn't actually sell my last
card is forgot where I parked it I don't
know who Al Gore is and at this point
I'm too afraid to ask when they say 2%
milk I don't know what the other 98% is
when I was a baby my head was so big
scientists experiments on me I once
threw beer as Swann and then it attacked
my niece Rebecca
that'll do Andrew you don't have to play
the unity concert but don't quit music
please honor of oh oh what is on your
face is that a disguise
clown paint ID badges are long overdue
security in this office park is a joke
last year I came to work with my spud
gun in a duffel bag I set up my desk all
day with a rifle that shoots potatoes at
60 pounds per square inch can you
imagine if I was deranged
okay well that's deeper let's say I
typed your symptoms into the thing up
here and it says you could have network
connectivity problems okay with all due
respect to everyone here I think the
most worthy opponent of you is you that
is correct unless there happened to be
measles present so let's just say that
Dwight has come at you with the throat
punch now how would you do it-- defend
against it easy allow me to demonstrate
i am attacking myself with a throat
punch here it comes
block grasp wrist as such and what if he
comes at you with the other hand because
he doesn't have to good point second
throat punch absorb the blow groin punch
hit block no bones in the gut Oh up to
the nose no you're not ah oh oh my god
he's making you look like such a fool he
really is but not for long Oh instep oh
not again ah you let go you let go oh
you're right look at hold on oh you're
so evenly matched I don't know how one
of you is gonna get the upper hand the
important thing to remember Jim we
always have what is called the element
of surprise
listen hit me up on my cell phone I'll
be around and you want to talk or grab
coffee or something like that okay okay
Oh gotta get back to the office have a
good one bye
and the hardest part about living in
this pit it's probably keeping my suit
pressed and the rats
it's like a freakin rat parade every
night they will cost you your life
elaborate the worst thing you can do for
your immune system is to coddle it they
need to fight their own battles
if saber really cared about our
well-being they would set up handy
sanitizing stations a simple Bowl at
every juncture filled with dirt vomit
fecal matter exposing yourself to germs
is the best way to make yourself
stronger so by that rationale only if I
had to sneeze I should just stays on you
yes I would welcome it you're welcome
the principle is sound to avoid illness
expose yourself to germs enabling your
immune system to develop antibodies hurt
you I don't know why everyone doesn't do
this maybe they have something against
living forever where's this do
[Music]
[Laughter]
seriously okay okay yes I have a wig for
every single person in the office you
never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone I
just want it to stop not giving up on
this he's not the only musician in town
Andy yeah I don't know let's see I don't
really feel like playing right now
Please Please Please Please Please I
don't even have children's songs my last
song I wrote was called sex hair well
just take the word sex and change it to
pickle pickle you've got pickle here
baby
and you got it from me sounds like it's
about sex I'm in I gotta grab my guitar
for my house I'll be back shortly
yeah see guys we have a solution and and
the good news is there's always a
solution and your motives are pure
[Music]
you